So, just to close off and recap this course, we've learned some best practice tips for
skeleton setup before we're bringing our vehicle meshes into the engine, and we now
know how to configure the physics asset and the wheel blueprints for our chaos vehicle,
and then connect these up to our vehicle's blueprint and animation blueprint.
And we've explored some of the settings that affect the vehicle's handling.
And lastly, we went over a control rig setup to use within our animation blueprint for
our suspension system to animate in real time, reacting to the movement of the wheels.
So you should be able to take this knowledge forward into your own projects and set up
your own chaos vehicles.
So thank you for following along with the course, and if there's more you want to learn
about control rig, we have other courses available covering the fundamentals and intermediate
topics like mechanical or procedural rigging.
Otherwise, thank you for your time, and best of luck creating your own chaos vehicle.